>> Sean: TIME NOW FOR A NEW
HANNITY WATCH SEGMENT THAT'S
THE VETTING OF THE 2020
RADICAL DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES LIKE WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU A NEW RADICAL
WING IS HAS NOW TAKEN OVER
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY PUSHING
AN AGENDA OF OPEN BORDERS,
HIGHER TAXES, MORE
GOVERNMENT CONTROL OF YOUR
LIFE AND, TODAY, CALIFORNIA
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS BECAME
THE LATEST TO ENTER THAT
2020 RACE AND WHILE OUR
CAMPAIGN KICKOFF FOCUSED ON
SO-CALLED UNITY AND JUSTICE,
BUMPER STICKERS, PLATITUDES,
HER COMMENTS AS A SITTING
SENATOR HAVE BEEN.
SO MOST DESPICABLE IN
WASHINGTON LIKE WHEN SHE
COMPARED BRAVE BORDER PATROL
AND ICE PEOPLE TO THE KKK.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE CLAN WAS WHAT WE
WOULD CALL TODAY A DOMESTIC
TERRORIST GROUP.
>> WHY?
WHY WOULD THEY CALL THEM
DOMESTIC TERRORIST GROUP?
>> BECAUSE THEY TRIED TO USE
FEAR AND FORCE TO CHAIN
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT.
>> ARE YOU AWARE OF THE
PERCEPTION OF MANY ABOUT HOW
THE POWER AND THE DISCRETION
AT ICE IS BEING USED TO
ENFORCE THE LAWS?
AND DO YOU SEE ANY
PARALLELS?
>> IF YOU HAD TO BE STUCK IN
AN ELEVATOR WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP MIKE PENCE OR JEFF
SESSIONS WHO WOULD IT BE?
>> DOES ONE OF US HAVE TO
COME OUT ALIVE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Sean: GETS FAR WORSE.
REMEMBER WHEN SHE GOT BUSTED
FOR RELEASING DECEPTIVE
VIDEO OF JUDGE KAVANAUGH AND
BIGOTRY BY GRILLING ONE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S JUDICIAL
NOMINEES OVER BELONGING TO
THE KNIGHTS OF COLUMBUS?
HOW IS THIS IN ANY WAY
UNIFY?
HOW IS THIS GOOD FOR THE
COUNTRY?
NOT JUST CRITICISM FROM THE
RIGHT.
HARRIS IS EVEN FACING
OPPOSITION FOR NOT BEING
PROGRESSIVE ENOUGH.
SENATOR HARRIS ISN'T THE
ONLY TROUBLING DEMOCRATIC
CANADA.
NEW YORK SENATOR KIRSTEN
GILLIBRAND LITERALLY STAKING
OUT HER SOCIALIST AGENDA TO
TRY TO WIN LOYALTY FROM THE
BASE OF THE FAR LEFT
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NOW GILLIBRAND APPEARS TO BE
LEARNING FROM HER MENTOR,
HILLARY CLINTON.
ABOUT THE POWER OF FLIPPING
AND FLOPPING TO TRY AND WIN
VOTES.
FOR EXAMPLE, THIS WEEK SHE
TOLD THE NEW YORK DAILY NEWS
SHE NOW FAVORS GIVING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS DRIVER'S
LICENSE AFTER COMING OUT
AGAINST THAT IN 2007, AND
DURING AN INTERVIEW ON ABC
ON SUNDAY SHE WAS PRESSED
ABOUT HER STARK SHIFT ON
IMMIGRATION BUT OFFERED FEW
SPECIFICS FOR THE CHANGE.
LIKE I HAVE BEEN SAYING,